endoscopy yeah i was like i was worse
than the hotel room we stayed and that
was like the worst thing i've ever had
in the world were you awake for that
yeah oh god i went i went to like the
worst doctor ever and
i thought it would be like a little
thing
right
and they had like this doctors was
really bad it's so bad that that it's
closed now i think it must have found my
health it's not
just like gagging for about 25 minutes
over and over are you sure you went to a
doctor
well might have just been like
and worst of all they they took the they
they had a screen in front of me like a
42 inch plasma screen of mike
and i was i didn't look at it once
because i was like no no no he's like
look you're throt and i was like
[ __ ]
and then they printed it out and they
pulled it out and it's just oh god it's
horrible you have to like a mouthpiece
and they feed it through it
it's almost it's up there with t
waterboarding uh but like it sounds like
a scene out of sauce yeah you know you
just did you just wake up and you just
got the mouse piece on that's honestly
mine you have to escape the endoscopy
you want to play a game
the worst
they were supposed to print out five
photos and after two photos they ran out
of paper
and the images were not stored anywhere
so they're lost
i saw the guy exasperated and like the
nurse they're like
oh and he looks at me like we we ran out
of pitch
and i was like that's how he's here yeah
he was he's spoken
right and like he sort of insinuated
that we should probably do it again oh
my god no no we're good we're fine don't
worry
no cancer we're good i'd like [ __ ] you
know
jesus what did you get
before what
really bad like stomach acids like three
why i discovered it basically i was
really stressed for a long period of
time really bad
i don't know when this was
uh i think stafford started going
youtube full-time
do youtube yeah it's great and i was
really stressed and burnt out and so on
my stomach was just acidic yeah yeah so
they did that and um
yeah [ __ ] it it was one it was probably
like the top three worst experience ever
got a really bad curvy test on that one
place and i was like wait what are we
doing it they were like oh just come
here follow us it looks like the [ __ ]
emergency stair stairway like outside
the fire escape yeah you do the same
thing oh that place
yeah and then he was like alright open
your mouth and i'm like
i was like why are we doing it outside
he's like oh because uh it's ventilated
the office isn't ventilated because if
you have covered we don't get it and i'm
like
i feel like there could have been a
better solution to this like
out in like overlooking like roppongi
just watching like everyone walk by
while i'm getting something shoved down
my throat god it's awful jesus as for
the place we went to before fly back to
england right yeah it's weird yeah
that experience is why i'm like i don't
think i need the doctor again
again
i've heard really good and just really
bad about japan never like oh yeah sorry
i think endoscopy is the worst thing you
could do in japan
i'm sure you can top it connor what have
you done that's bad the ear thing is
pretty bad oh [ __ ] what the ear
cleaning services for fun
it's horrible that is horrible because
you know i don't clean my ears
you don't no gross graceful a lot most
doctors recommend not to put anything in
your ear oh really nothing should ever
be going in your ears because i water it
and if you if you're watering it would
come out you'd call it a smack you
shouldn't put cotton buds in your ear
even on the package the cotton buds say
they say
so you know this guy goes in and starts
scraping the [ __ ] drums and stuff he
goes so
yeah but people love it on youtube for
some reason people absolutely it's like
pimple popping videos yeah that's the
same genre i helped sharla film her
video she did it once i think it made
loads of views and she's like everyone
loves this i'm gonna do it again yeah i
want to film it i was like yeah sure i
went along and you get like a live feed
yeah it's awful on a big thing there or
is it with live feeds
[ __ ] inch plasma screen tv and you
you're like the optimal viewing angle
that you can't look away it's like
watching june it's like it was so i was
like nearly gagging while watching i had
to like look away dude
i had to
stop him at one point and be like i
gotta go and i need to go and sit on the
toilet i was just like i was like lying
on this toilet bowl just like
and then i was was that from was that
though from him going into your ear or
from the footage both both so like just
seeing
seeing the footage combined with like it
was really painful yeah i don't ever
touch my ears yeah i don't know it's
probably super sensitive so it's super
sensitive obviously people who clean
their rooms all the time it's not a big
deal you know you can do it but i
haven't done it and this guy's going ham
on me
he's good at what he does
boss man knows how to do it don't get me
wrong but holy [ __ ] i was not ready and
then he was like no we're not done yet
we just get a deep clean and he starts
going deeper and it really feels like
he's like really inside like i would
have never put anything even closer
scratching your eardrum really far to a
point where i was genuinely concerned
and you know some some doctors are like
yeah it's a load of [ __ ] this whole ear
cleaning stuff doesn't do anything and
it's dangerous because you can pop your
trunks yeah yeah yeah it was yeah it was
genuinely like i wouldn't do it again um
that was it wasn't my idea it was it was
one of them right i was like yeah
whatever sure i mean it sounds
disgusting but they
did they find anything how much do they
clean oh like a [ __ ] they find anything
okay
a society is here
after a flooded past and the sewage
system has been cleaned out yeah it was
like
it was like the red sea parting in my
ears that you finally see in there but i
mean you know it was um it was
not fun because i i actually bought one
of the those ear picker things with the
camera at the end of it yeah like you
can you can get sydney yeah you can you
can like you can connect it on your
phone to see it yeah no i i remember i
remember i clean my ears pretty often
i remember one time a few a few years
ago actually now um so me and cindy went
swimming once in a pool right and so one
one time we went swimming and we went
out and she had some water stuck in her
ears and normally you just
shake it out yeah yeah shake it out so
this water just would not get out of
here
so it would it was stuck in there and i
was just like just just lay like that
just like that it's fine it's fine um
and it just packed and so this water
just wouldn't come out i don't know
where this is going yeah so i say so he
stayed in there for like days to the
point where her ears started hurting
because i guess
so you get like an ear infection so we
actually had to go to the doctor right
so we took her to the doctor and the
doctor tries cleaning her ears and they
can't like for some reason they can't
get this liquid out right so it's really
disgusting even hearing that yeah so so
what they had to do was they had to they
put this solution in right there's some
kind of solution which like softens the
ear wax yeah yeah yeah so they put the
solution in and left it in for like a
good few minutes right i didn't know
what i was expecting uh because i didn't
know how i didn't know what was blocking
her ear canal this bad and so they put
this they put the uh put the liquid in
drain it and then to get like this uh
mini mini kind of vacuum kind of thing
just like vacuum out but kind of clean
the ear right yeah
all right so i just remember i just so i
just remember right i just remember
sydney lying down and the nurse just
like vacuuming vacuuming vacuuming her
ear out right just waiting for something
to come out and then out plops this ball
of black earwax like you could hear the
splat on the ground like this this
wasn't ear wax this was like a [ __ ]
lovecraftian nightmare creature nothing
it was like the thing i swear to god
like i was not expecting that right not
even the nurse was because like this
this ball just drops out of her ear and
me and the nurse are just looking at
this ball like eyes wide open and
just like takes takes it and sydney's
like what what what what what what and
uh she's like what's happened but like
i'm just like sydney you do not want to
see what just came out of your [ __ ]
yeah it was massive i didn't know that i
didn't know earwax could get that big
because i've had that before as well
because i have like really naturally
very tough earwax like it's like very
dry earwax top trunks in there yeah it's
like it's like naturally really really
dry the smelliest
mine's like naturally really dry so if i
don't clean it out consistently then it
hardens and turns into like rock form
and then yeah that's when you get like
the whole water stuck in your ear yeah
you're infection
i used to get here
if you start doing it it just starts
happening and then sure i have to i used
to get ear infections all the time as a
kid because i had this like rock hard
knee or an infection
yeah i mean once when a bumblebee went
in my ear and stung in my ear
that triggered an ear infection yeah
oh this is horrible how was that oh well
how'd it get in there i was like six
running around in the field having fun
that was the last time chris had fun
ever
after that the last one the laughter
i can't even do it yourself [ __ ] air
cleaning disgusting do-it-yourself
colonoscopy yeah
apparently it's like a thing that
japanese couples do they clean each
other's ears and stuff it's you say
colonoscopy
all right
you laugh but there's probably a couple
or two that are there
yeah no my mom used to clean my ears all
the time when i was little that's
probably why you're getting like ear
infections because she started the cycle
of cleaning you're not supposed to go in
there though yeah you're not supposed to
put anything in there like it's i don't
know why but japan is obsessed with
being cleaned that's probably why i love
the trash taste podcast you learn about
the important things yeah hygiene top of
the list who needs anime anymore i just
play more anime it's just
an infection oh you've had an ear
infection no i've never had one yeah i
used to get them all the time it was
horrible yeah i mean i feel like the wax
is like a natural barrier of shorts no
it is it is
conspiracy it is
natural i mean it's it's there for a
reason right it's like dust and [ __ ]
getting in but there are some times when
there is just a big buildup of wax and
it just gets like it really gets itchy
are there bidets
uh i mean yeah like doctors have them
maybe they're doing the air bubbles
[Music]
get a bottle and just